now careful you might you might want to
close your eyes with this first half
because
it's going to have you feeling some kind
of way
okay just
look at my boy right here look at this
oh chill out bro
oh oh oh
annihilated that beer is gone
holy [ __ ] that like cylinder motion he
did
that's like i know that's like watching
this
take notes babe throw me up in the air
like that and just cylinder my [ __ ] like
that
hold me by the hips and cylinder my [ __ ]
like that i
poured it to kelsey like so what do you
think
pretty wild huh how he drank that first
one
i mean it's like a good seems like a
good technique
she's like for chugging yeah chugging
beer chugging like whatever
brother wait
that foam just went and he went i was
like oh
keep going this is this is nine yeah
you're like can you can you run it back
can we start from the meeting
yeah let's see that again no but can we
talk about how
actually effective that is i guess for
chugging because it creates what it
creates like an air thing in the middle
that
i guess yeah everything yeah so it can
just drain into your
throat could you admit bro can you
imagine being at a frat party like
you're like a freshman
and you're like trying to impress and
everyone's like okay like you think you
can chug [ __ ] nathan like show us
what's good and you're like [ __ ]
and you like pop it and you're like you
do that whole thing and then you stick
it up in the air and you're like
they're all like
yo why do i have a boner right now
why do i think i like guys right now
dude nathan you are making me feel in a
way i have never felt in my entire life
you are in brother
[Laughter]
just wait man now what do you think are
in those wine glasses what do you think
i would guess wine yeah well but the top
one kind of looks like water
uh well it's flammable so okay
okay
wait watch this you're not even ready
for this
look at this look at this
are you kidding me are you kidding me
oh my god this dude is the coolest guy
on the planet are you kidding me
finger into the fire water my cigarette
that's so cool now
look at this frame he just what a
[ __ ]
hard ass he just slugged that [ __ ]
beer
just what an absolute beast torpedoed
that [ __ ] now
just i love this man just wait
count it two you thought he was done
put that red [ __ ] in there ash that
cigarette a little bit of protein
for good measure and
this dude this guy absolutely should be
on america's got talent that's so insane
our vaginas got down or wherever he
lives
no world has talent we got to do the
global show
yeah seriously yeah we got to do the
olympics of
uh america's got talent and we got to
send our best people i'm saying we send
him
the girl who can you know from early in
the podcast
who can one one suck the gigantic gummy
worm
oh my god i forgot about that
oh yeah but did we have a bit about her
on america's got talent yeah yeah the
golden buzzers that's what i'm saying
that we sent
we don't know he's china it was x factor
right
i'm saying we sent him but he's chinese
so we can't
but bro if we had to compete against
this i think our only shot would be
you know yeah gummy suck girl
[Laughter]
the russian the russia's russia's
american downtown will be some guy who
can like
who can like dead lift like a [ __ ]
empty fiat with his pinkies like you
know something with just sheer power
oh my god i love this guy holy [ __ ]
yeah man here's the thing though now
after watching that i want
to try i want to be his i don't want to
yeah i want a drink first of all and i
also want to be his friend but
he'll always just be the fat guy yeah
that yeah yeah but he is uh
i don't ever want to hear anyone go dude
i'm an alcoholic no you're not
yeah yeah no why because you're drinking
on a tuesday
yeah see you later the this the bar has
been raised
man alcoholics got to work harder
after this go back oh you want to see
him you want to see him do it
yeah yeah you want to see him blow this
[ __ ] uh
this foamy pen pipe right here i want to
see him commence suck
down on these this is a this is the beer
pan pipe
oh what have to throw the sunglasses on
yeah why does he do the eggs i don't
know
no but wait wait pause it one two three
four five six seven pints of beer plus
one two
sorry sorry sorry six shots dude
and that's one of the things about this
video you know it's alcohol because it's
lighting it's on fire is there any other
thing is there anything else that lights
on fire that he could drink
butane you can't drink that
i mean just a little bit yeah what if
it's just straight up like
like moonshine just a little butane in
it on top of water it's cool
it's good like what if that was grain
liquor
oh so it's just like 3000 proof
certified destroy your [ __ ] body
yeah why don't the eggs man the eggs
this is
why digestion like
i don't know he's so random
dude he's just trying to say
to the maximum degree i don't give a
[ __ ] because two eggs is like your daily
value for cholesterol he's like i don't
care
now watch me hit this beer pan pipe
if you're listening on audio you have to
be watching this on video this guy is
i'm i'm surprised um we've never like
talked about this before
i felt like he went like pretty viral
just on everything like instagram
tick tock whatever because my [ __ ] i
i'd swear i like went into my barber
shop one day and he's like he's seen
that [ __ ] chinese fool who like
drinks all the [ __ ] beer
[ __ ] like what do we think you think his
tolerance is just so high
yeah that he can slam this and be
totally fine or do you think he
he did this video and he just goes
straight to the hospital [ __ ]
he gets the stomach pump immediately
yeah yeah
yeah first he makes himself puke like
right after they stop filming he's like
you're good cool
and then he goes straight to hell to the
maybe he's got like a medical
professional like on-site
he just jams a thing in his thing just
pumps his stomach
well he's still awake or he just hits it
all and he's like all right let's go
out yeah there this is this pregame
everyone's like i don't think you're
good man he's like i'm fine
i'm fine trust me dude i'm so good if
anything it's the eggs that are making
me feel weird
my body's you know i'm not great with
with eggs
my cholesterol is a little high so this
is really the risky part of this whole
thing
bro you want okay let's see let's watch
them suck this [ __ ] down
oh wait what the bro come on
twitter video gets my developer rage
going
so fast man yeah i have
like in terms of things i have no
patience for
there is nothing above twitter video
yeah i think i get so irrationally angry
and video
video is like the hardest thing to
[ __ ] develop though
it it is but i tried to do in-feed
granted this was like what five six
years ago
yeah but i tried to do in-feed videos
one time that played automatically
and then you could like tap on them to
pause them like instagram it was
definitely the hardest thing i've ever
worked on in my entire life
oh bro i when i had to rip out the web
player module for like
landing pages for full screen yeah
[ __ ] jeff and those guys were like
always caveat like uh
just like want to let you know the code
is um
they're like uh they didn't even like i
remember their their vibe kind of being
like uh
i don't know we could rip it like our he
straight up goes
i mean we could rip it out i don't know
if it's gonna work
[Laughter]
like just so funny to be like yeah the
code only works one way man
so yeah yeah sorry
all right let's see him suck it down
so much fire that's why he has to wear
the sunglasses yeah
thumbs up oh that's a long thumbs up
i think he's uh getting in the zone whoa
oh no he didn't
this is dude this guy this guy's got a
throat
he does the eggs one second why
oh maybe it's sake maybe
that doesn't make it better or like soju
or something yeah but it's less
percentage than just
straight up like yeah what if it's just
like some kind of like um like
rice based wine yeah
still man
i feel like even a seasoned alcoholic
would be pretty
[ __ ] up from all this
he's no he's got no problem he just had
to let that burp out let the gas go
oh my god man
all right we're [ __ ] going out all
right let's go yo call the uber
i'd love to see some [ __ ] college
girl attempt the same [ __ ] and just
[ __ ] collapse
like on the fourth journey he's like
that's [ __ ]
just some [ __ ] just some college bro
just like
dude i'm gonna do it man the fat guy
challenge this is for my boy
shout out to you and he gets to three
and he just
crying yeah he's crying somebody call my
[ __ ] mom
yeah this guy's like the chinese steve
will do it you know
yeah he is oh my god him and steve will
do it
in the epic battle royale
they'll they'll they'll go at it and
whoever
wins gets to keep tick-tock
yeah that's good i like that
that's really good the chinese guy
wins and trump's like uh well oh [ __ ] i
got
can't say can't say i don't respect what
you've you've achieved here tonight
oh it is what it is
you will always be the fat guy that we
just met
and you guys can have tick tock